today's topic we got a video here from
the cut where people have to guess what
language a person's speaking while
blindfolded
i figured meme priest could take the
challenge
because of the fact that we both are
into a vast
diverse set of languages yeah we'll do
it without watching the screen
how do you think you're gonna do on this
one i think i'm gonna fail miserably i
think i'm gonna do all right
i think i'm gonna do all right i'm used
to hearing a lot of fun unless it's like
some random language like
here's the thing if i could see them
written and written it would also help
me a little bit
if i'm just listening it might be a bit
tough but i'm pretty decent with
languages
i can't tell the difference between twee
and lingard
if you guess the country we'll just
leave it at that that's what i'll say
do you know what you're doing i will be
listening to somebody speak a language
that i don't know and i'm going to guess
what they're speaking
about
[Music]
oh this is a tough one cambodia
this is a tough one can you bring it is
it possible for you to bring it back
[Music]
that eats papaya salad
mango papaya salad something like that
someone that eats lot
i think it's cambodia lao okay i'm not
mad at that that's actually a really
good guess
i know i know it's not far from korea
walking or
[ __ ] plane [ __ ] you can't walk from
korea to any country
except for north
[Laughter]
you can walk in the bottom of the sea
you know what i mean spongebob
apparently apparently for our american
audience korea's an island
uh scientist you piece of [ __ ]
you ain't shipping that one but i agree
and you know what's wrong
a lot of americans like appreciate the
clarification
thank you very much buddy we appreciate
it um
cambodia lao something like that yeah
i'm going to say i'm going to say taiwan
did you say you're not gay
sorry what do you mean
[Music]
yeah did i get it right did i yeah you
got it right okay that was a good guess
someone that eat papaya salad
hey i'm not even mad at that once you
said it i was like you're probably going
to get it
that was good
[Music]
it really makes me think of a playing
football i used to do hot
hot seven
this one's giving me vibes of uh of a
conflict in the west bank
uh i'm gonna say it's hebrew egypt
hebrew oh it's possible
it just sounds like contempt for other
people you know like i got money
and the only people who i know are arabs
uh and in in uh you know in hebrews the
people speak arabic and people who speak
hebrew
and arabic people i know what it sounds
like when i hear arabic
the devil is not something you would
find in arabic that's why i feel like
that
that would be more like a more more
hebrew
is that it is
how did you get that i don't know is
that your first language it's not i
actually
i love languages yeah so obviously you
can write hebrew write and read and
speak
does it go left or right or right left
it goes right to left
so some somatic languages are like that
uh arabic is also like that goes right
to left so when you're writing it
and it's funny because sometimes i'll
read like mangas and if you read
japanese mangas they also go right to
left so
sometimes when you're so used to english
you just come back you're like what the
[ __ ]
uh but some language write it right that
way it's fun to speak too with all the
guttural mm-hmm
yep and like the attack
well that's definitely eastern european
that just sounded like that sounded like
the ussr is not going to back down for
the german forces okay that was
that sounded like vladimir putin riding
a horse without a shirt on okay let's go
but
more pissed off so ukrainian yes that
sounded like
polish pavel you have not reached the
final level
that's what that sounded like
oh yeah that's russian or
either i have a hard time doing the
difference and i know y'all gonna be
pissed off about that yeah but it's
either ukraine it's either
retrain or ruski the only words that i
know in russian is
productive and robestein
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right so we both got it so i think
we're now we're tied 3-3 oh
[Laughter]
i don't know russia's a big plan it's
just a setup for it
it's because it's a black guy
you know like a big sort of the other
stereotype the big
beer belly russian angry white guy with
him i gotta drink more beer and hang out
in the summer
maybe the cold yeah you're not going to
get that that close to that story
this guy wanted to look wider he's like
i gotta hang out in the sun
i don't think that's how it works
brother
[Music]
wow this is difficult that sounds close
to japanese but not
japanese i haven't heard of them enough
like that sounds close to japanese but
not japanese it could be korean
but no my first thing what was the east
european that's what i would say
first first thing like i haven't heard
anything what they're gonna say just a
couple of words and that's it can you
count to five nick
hoyer it
sounded like like something between like
uh
japan japanese
japanese mandarin
maybe something like from uzbekistan
like it sounds like it's that area
because some of the language words i
think i have heard before
but it definitely sounds asian like in
that area you said what
korea no it's not korean if you don't
hear
if you don't hear if you don't hear them
sound like they're complaining it's not
korean
here we go damn this is brutal
okay okay this is it's not
mandarin but it's [ __ ] close
something like that but
yo you cut it off can you bring it back
can you count to five
nick hoyer
there was like a word in it that sounded
like like like korean maybe she's just
speaking in korean without intentions
no i don't okay well listen what's your
guess i'll keep playing it then i'll
stop
ching is hot okay there's oh i know what
it is i figured out what it is
okay is that what you're going with okay
it's mongolian
oh dude
that would make a lot of [ __ ] sense
yep yep yep yep yep i had a feeling it
was that area or something like that
because it sounded like a mixture of a
couple of things but then at the end she
said she said genghis khan
which is genghis khan so yeah it's it's
mongolia
what'd you just say
mongolian yes that was cheating
but i'm not gonna lie to you i was
leading between
uh taiwan and mongolia those are the two
places i knew it was around china
because some of those words sounded
super chinese
she threw that one out yeah well she
said jen
jengas yeah when she said that it was
like okay i think i know
hi nice to meet you i don't know if you
like mongolian or not but
i know everyone thinks i look korean so
when did you leave
mongolia about 10 years ago okay cool
i've been to mongolia
oh you have yeah but i didn't learn any
mongolian at all but then you couldn't
say it
you did not guess it i heard genghis
khan that's like the only thing everyone
knows well you shouldn't have said it
then
you almost got me
[Music]
that sounds like pakistani or that
sounds like
pakistan pakistan make sure you gotta
say it right
pakistan you gotta go [ __ ] your stun
that sounds cool
you think it's farsi yeah
i think he said it i think he said it
bring it back
[Music]
i don't think it's farsi this doesn't
sound like farsi this sounds like a
cross between a south asian country
and i like um if i had to put a point
like
geographically speaking i would say it's
like somewhere between india
and indonesia like i was about to see
singapore
singapore yeah some [ __ ] like that but
yeah i see what you're saying yeah it's
not funny i'm gonna
i'm gonna say i'm gonna say sri lanka
that's gonna be wrong yes
what about you i'm gonna stick to
thailand okay there's something about
the location of the pronunciation in the
mouth
that reminds me a little bit of um a
hindi pronunciation
let's go okay i'm not far off my
negative my translator okay okay cool
i'm not free
pakistan pakistan pakistan yeah
it was something like that yeah yeah you
could definitely hear a bit of hindi but
i don't know this language i've never
heard it
okay yeah you can take off here
oh damn no see oh you were very close
oh damn it so how close are indian are
you then well hindi and urdu are both
dialects of hindustani
and the similarities between hindi and
urdu is like 95
okay okay so yeah pakistan would have
been the guess yeah
i said sri lanka so i i wasn't uh i
wasn't that much closer you're not far
off
with sri lanka technically you know yeah
sri lanka bangladesh you know i mean all
my bengali people
stand up it was all the same thing and
then he broke off you know
i mean i actually don't know if that's
the case but i'll take your word for it
i think it is i wouldn't
you wouldn't you wouldn't die on the
sword for this one someone because you
know there's some south asian people
watch us
uh actually preach historically speaking
and they're gonna get on you so
yeah but i know they were together and
then they just split okay i think
[Music]
this is definitely an african dialect
i'm going to also say
just by listening to it this is a black
woman
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah i think she might be
from congo all right
okay they're giving me all the hard ones
can you say hello
oh i know where this is what is it this
is i think
niger no okay but listen i'm gonna let
it keep going and then we'll decide
are you let's see okay i'm gonna say
it's between angola
or madagascar for me i'm not gonna say
angola
i'm still gonna stick to congo okay all
right let's find out i'm guessing this
is an
uh african language with uh some
influence from france
okay there we go i think i'm getting
i've got as close as i'm gonna get
what do i think i look like i think you
look like what do you think i look like
[ __ ] just say a black woman
you are a non-white
there's some sarah in africa why why
because i'm
the theory that i'm working on right now
is that uh you're you're from an african
country that was colonized by um by
friends
and so um there's a small chance you
look like a white french person but i
guess
i sort of doubt it was insulting
insulting i got that 99
there we are it's not insulting how
close was i i'm from
congo and we were colonized by belgium
hey congo
let's go [ __ ] i'll give you that one
thank you that was good
that was good that was good that was
good and you know all the congolese
people are gonna get so offended if you
don't guess it right [ __ ] how did you
not know
bruh a lot of people don't know lingala
chill okay just eat your fufu
okay and leave me alone you know that
eddie king's gonna
be in our dmv like uh how
[Music]
[Laughter]
we can't even do that accent right so
benchy and longer
near you you like it off does she say
you like it rough
can you bring it back so for bentley and
longer near you
you like to like it off it's dutch baby
what does a dutch person look like dutch
person
they are blonde and have pigtails and i
was gonna go with dutch
yeah yeah because of like some of the
english words like i was gonna say dutch
like uh
big skirts and they milk cows
hello they sent me up you know every
time
is it dutch it is dungeon okay uh nobody
learns dutch as a second language for
fun so you must have been born in
the netherlands and so i'm from the
caribbean oh she might be strong
same with a martin saint barn yeah saint
martin no not she could be
that's right let's find out let's find
out yeah we live in saint martin
it's an island you're right you're right
there you go the st
martin is fresh we have friendship
there's saints
martin and there's semata which is
half half of the island yeah i've been
there it's really nice
man these are some weird sounds go ahead
what are you thinking
i thought it was mohawk but i don't
think it is no i don't think it would be
mohawk
oh okay i was actually going for um
polynesian i was going for i wrote
yeah lilo polynesian is not a language
but they should have a language it's
maori or something i don't know they
don't have
one language polynesian don't have one
language you have different
languages and different dialects
depending tonga people don't speak the
same thing
as uh samoan as maoris they have
you're right you're right but i would
have said a polynesian language and i
probably would it's like saying
it's just like saying african languages
it's it's not a thing
it's not a thing they have different
lagging like polynesia
is an area of different islands that are
scattered throughout
the pacifica but they have different
ways of speaking habians
don't speak the same way like i said
tonga and
all those new zealand like yeah
what are the seven polynesian islands
and and the population is 700 000 people
so
yeah would i compare it to africa no
no but i'm not not in terms of but but
you get what i'm saying like knowing the
difference is very unlikely for most
people because it's such a small
population size
you wouldn't you know what i'm saying
that's why that's only different system
yeah i get what you say i got i got a
tattoo so i got to know this [ __ ]
yeah yeah you got to say something the
rest of us are like i've never even seen
somebody from the island yeah i can't i
can't be having all them tattoos
the only polynesian person i know
personally is like
lilos and and the rock so i'm going to
go
randomly in a different direction and
guess that this is a native american
language of some sort
uh how do you say no in your language
well then maybe that was a yes huh
hey eric yes obviously there's
something more specific so um i speak
mukah
okay or kuwaiti from the indian
reservation
out of near bay washington yeah when i
said
i was not too far off you weren't you
weren't if you hadn't get it
if you hadn't given up on the guests i
would have given it to you because he
said
quick way was qui i think quick way in
mohawk means
that's how you that's how you greet
someone when he said quick way
that was said something something quick
way i thought you thought yeah you
should have stuck with it you should
have stuck with it you did good
yeah i can't be sporting my section 35
shirt
without you know prepping for you know
yeah yeah you're just rocking every l
you're walking every [ __ ] shirt
from every country that's your problem
every first nation
i got it yeah all right it's a draw it's
a draw
but it's a i'm gonna say this it's a
draw
but i felt like you came very close on
the mohawk but you gave up on it but
then i also said the sri lankan one
which is very close as well so i didn't
give myself that point so we'll just say
it's a draw we'll say it's a wash
yeah but then again you know i rock all
these things but if i rock it i know
about it
i don't rock it and not know about it
because it's cool yeah i mean not
affiliated
that's the important [ __ ] about it oh
[ __ ] and they could have definitely
gotten spice here with some of the
choices
they could have they could have gotten
much spicier with some of them but they
uh it was interesting
i was impressed by some of the guesses
you got though like with cambodia
cambodia no cambodia i could understand
because i was i i i felt like
okay the lingala one that was good
was good and you guessed another one too
i got a couple i guess a couple
you got three three yeah you got three
you said say martin i said quran
but that wasn't for a point but yeah we
were just playing that was cool i got
the whole thing you got yeah but but it
was
it was a 50 50 thing though you know i
mean no because yeah we both got touched
yeah exactly yeah yeah whatever yeah
i'm happy that they didn't go like okay
so what is that
french i know you know
some easy [ __ ] but uh but yeah that was
it for today's video what did you guys
think could you guys tell who it was
but how many did you guys guess right
did you guys cheat or not we want to
hear from you
that's it for today's video tell us what
you see
and if you guys enjoyed today's video if
you have fun if you like this kind of
content leave a like
leave a comment let us know and
encourage us to do more things
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
you